[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world and pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather roofs and I'm Ayano aid and
this is your news for Monday March 19th
first of all we're gonna talk about some
titans casting news and no no this time
we're not talking about the DC streaming
service Titans that we've been talking
about for a while but we're actually
talking about it's way worse stepchild
Teen Titans go which has done something
that might actually give me to go see
the movie and that they cast Nicolas
Cage as Superman
so Nicolas Cage is going to finally be
able to play Superman I mean now it's
animated rather than Superman lives
movie that never actually got me it
didn't live it but he's finally got boy
Superman and I hate to say it but I
think this might be a good fit because I
think Nicolas Cage's brand of insanity
might just fit with a brand of insanity
that is Teen Titans go so it might
actually work and along with this we've
also learned that a little yadi the
rapper is going to be playing Green
Lantern and singer Halsey is going to be
playing Wonder Woman which does make
sense because there are musical numbers
for some reason and Teen Titans Co you
know yourselves
sure yeah so it does make sense I guess
we're definitely gonna get some rapping
Green Lantern and singing Wonder Woman
and I can only hope there's going to be
some kind of random rap battle between
Nicolas Cage Superman and little yachty
Green Lantern my god it's gonna be
ridiculous
I mean if that does actually make you
want to go see the movie it does you do
have until July 27th to make up your
mind I still don't know I don't know if
I want to go support it in theatres I'm
not gonna lie or net it's gonna
Slade Wow yes our night will arnett will
be playing Slade sounds like it's a it's
a stacked cast yeah gonna be weird I
don't know do you need to know I do know
July 28th there we go there we go um
this week we also got news of The Grudge
getting a reboot that's right we already
got an American remake of in 2004 of the
Japanese original but we're getting a
reboot all the same it will be one of
the producers is going to be Sam Raimi
and it will be written and directed by
Nicolas pêche a relative newcomer it
seems to the scene he has a couple of
horror and thriller movie credits under
him like the eyes of my mother but not
much so I'm really excited to see what
he brings to the table or even if
they're going to mention the the last
grudge that we saw the American one I
have no idea what to expect but I will
say Sam Raimi being attached to this
project does give me hope
also the cast looks pretty cool so far
they just signed John Chow from Star
Trek along with Demian Bichir from Pei
fleets and Andrea Riseborough from
Birdman so that's pretty cool so I'm
interested to see what storyline it's
going to be I'm suiting it'll be
relatively similar but we don't know the
production begins in May but other than
that we don't have any release dates
because they haven't really started it
yet so we'll see also this week we got
an announcement that there are talks for
a new Clarissa explains it all sequels
show going on with Nickelodeon so yes
children the 90s rejoice that snap is
coming back and Melissa Joan Hart is in
talks to replay Clarissa again but this
time as an adult so we're kind of going
with this trend now of remaking old
sitcoms but with the old cast as adults
so
looking at you fuller house Girl Meets
World
Ravens home mm-hmm so it also is in
talks that the original creator Mitchell
cry gift Craig man is going to be coming
back as well which is great know if he
created it and wrote it to begin with it
would be perfect if he could continue it
and he's actually already written a book
that continued on with klarissa's
journey where she was in her 20s and
couldn't quite explain it so it'll be
interesting to see if this is going to
be titled something like Clarissa can't
explain it all and kind of shows her
struggles as a mother and how to
navigate the current landscape of
motherhood which can be rough so it'll
be really interesting to see how that
plays out I think it is a great news
that we have some of the original
creative team coming back if you're
gonna do something like this that's the
way to do it get the people who had the
magic happen the first time around
invested and involved in the project
even further so again we have no release
dates about anything with this because
it's still kind of in talks right now
but you can probably find it on
Nickelodeon since they're in talks with
Nickelodeon also this week we got a
couple of trailers first off we did want
to talk about the fantastic beast
trailer which looks super cool and has
my Harry Potter nerd sense of tangling
I've loved seeing all that extra world
diving basically any excuse to watch
some more Harry Potter lore is a good
excuse for me I will say and I know I'm
not the only one that had an issue with
it but starting out the like second shot
of that trailer operating on to Hogwarts
grounds was no no you can't do that not
like you're not allowed to like there's
rules against it um the her money of me
wants to mention if you read your
Hogwarts of history there are charms and
spells that keep you from doing that
always no no no can't do it uh it's not
how charms work even if you're
Dumbledore mm well Dumbledore will just
program the
charm so that he can do it no no no that
was a major plot point in the books and
the movies
that's why Harry Potter can't just go to
you know school he has to steal a flying
car
that's why Baltimore can't just show up
and be like you did you did you did
everybody's dead that's that's a main
plot point so there's a reason that
these things exist I'm not sure what the
toying with here not happy the rest of
it made me real happy though so I was
quickly almost ready to forgive that
because me and it looks super cool I
will say that magical carnival oh my
gosh it's so excited about that because
it seems like there's so much room for
creativity with that for a magical
carnival yes bring it on and we did get
that shot of the deluminator so we got
some Dumbledore what's taking notes and
streetlights hmm makes me nostalgic for
a time I didn't actually exist and but
it's still really cool I will say Jude
Law seems really cool as Dumbledore
jury's still out on that I'm not sure
still how I feel on him I'll wait until
I see his full performance obviously but
for now chill yeah super chill chiller
then movies Dumbledore that we have
issues with too Harry Potter did you put
your name in the Goblet of Fire
that is no no any news we also got that
cool Deathly Hallows with that theme
song drops and with the end of the
trailer yeah really cool right right uh
so I'm looking really forward to that up
the costumes are gonna be amazing
yes so true another trailer we got this
week that just has us Heights so hype is
a new trailer for infinity wars and you
guys guys it looks so good and there was
so much happening in this trailer and I
appreciate when they have a second
trailer like this that has so much new
content for us to see that Spidey suit
oh we end at Tom Holland was doing
mmm-hmm odd point loved it um I loved
that we got to see a little child Gamora
baby oh my gosh I'm sure tiny Lillian
I'm so excited to see us delve into the
Gamora Thanos relationship because it
even started with her doing a vo saying
about how like in the comics we're
letting effect from snap um he can wipe
out the universe or part of the universe
with just a snap of his fingers if he
gets all of the Infinity stones I love
some of the character interactions that
we had we got to see some super sassy
moments between star-lord and Iron Man
which is worth great because they're
like hood the captains of SAS the Marvel
Universe and then we also had great
moments between spider-man and doctor
and Doctor Strange there at the end I
loved that with like oh we're using our
made-up names really quick my
predictions is that we are definitely
going to see Captain America died
exactly I don't think Steve Rogers is
gonna make it through this movie you
know we got to see him as you were just
saying fighting against the Infinity
Gauntlet there and he just had such
primal rage on his face in that moment I
loved it but I really don't think he's
gonna make it nor do I think Iron Man's
gonna make it and I think they're gonna
have one more shock death in there just
just for fun just for fun but you can
see that on April 27th apparently you
guys are already excited to see that
because it broke box office records yeah
great sales so we're all gonna go see it
Oh 20 something we also mark Panther go
see it again if you can cuz it's amazing
right but we also get what kind of
coming back yes that's gonna be it from
us here you guys it was a little bit of
a slower week for us but if we miss
anything let us know in the comments
down below otherwise we'll meet you
tomorrow on top 5 or right back here
same time same place on orbit report in
the meantime can you beat us up
[Applause]
you